- [Voiceover] So, we're
sold that suppose a plus b
is equal to zero.
Which of these expressions
equal a times b?
And like always, pause the video,
and see if you can figure it out.
These are actually pretty fun problems.
Alright, so, let's see if we can
do a little bit of manipulation.
So, we're told that a
plus b is equal to zero.
So, if we subtract b from both sides,
we would get.
So, if I subtract b from both sides,
I would get a is equal to negative b.
So, what is a time b equal to?
So, a times b.
Well, I could write this a few ways.
I could substitute the
a with a negative b,
since we know a is equal to negative b.
In which case, a times b
would be negative b times b,
which is equal to negative b squared.
Another option is I could
instead of saying a is
equal to negative b,
I could say that b is equal to negative a
if we multiply both
sides times negative one.
So, b is equal to negative a.
And so, instead of substituting
a, I could substitute b
with negative a.
And so, this expression
would be a times negative a,
a times negative a,
which is equal to negative a squared.
So, let's see, which of
these choices are there?
There's a b squared, by
not negative b squared.
So, we see the negative a
squared right over there.
So, I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling good about that choice.